so what about it CU they love bringing
up that one where he's like well I
didn't come to abolish the law well I
can show you what that means that's yeah
they misquote that to me all the time
chos yeah okay Matthew 5:17 to 20 that
one that shows you they don't know
context and you let them get away with
it because Jesus begins speaking in
Matthew 5 but he doesn't finish the
discussion to Matthew 7:27 right
specifically to 29 so what did he mean
by do not think I came to destroy the
law and the prophets I did not come to
destroy but
fulfill the the way I I don't know I'm
going let you I'm going let you cook
though but I don't know have you read
the rest of it I have I have so what
does he say there in the rest of it you
heard it was said but I right right he's
trying to the way when I first read it
it's like he's trying to give you a
prescription to surpass the
righteousness of the Pharisees now we
know it's only through Christ that makes
us right how do you surpass
because it's not just by following the
law by its letter there's more to it
there's a heart of the matter that
Christ is highl matter it's following
him because he he fulfills it that's
what he just said you heard what it said
but I say to you you heard what said but
I say to you in fact doesn't all allow
you to
swear like take Oaths oh yeah but he
says don't even do that no just say yes
yes no no anything beyond this is of the
devil so he can't be telling you to
slavishly follow the law when he's
in it right right changing its
application right right why are
you you're supposed to follow his
commands because how does he end that
discourse in Matthew 7 24- 27 whatever
here's my word these words of mine and
puts them in practice these words of
mine Matthew 7 2427 is like a man who
built his house on the rock and it stood
he didn't say the law of Moses these
words of mine right right so the
Fulfillment of the law and the prophets
doesn't mean I tell you to follow every
jot TI No I have come to fulfill them
they're fulfilled in me meaning they
point to me so I am the Fulfillment I
complete the law and the prophets I
perfect the law of the prophets they're
consummated in me so now you follow me
and my commands and my application of
the law of the prophets because that
word doesn't mean to follow it means to
complete because they were incomplete
waiting for Christ to consummate all
that they were pointing to I'll prove it
to you you see that word fulfill do not
came to
destroy but I came to fulfill let me
show you how the word fulfill is used by
Matthew go to Matthew 1
22:23 watch that word fulfill used by
Matthew got you all right all right I'm
there um it says now all this took place
so that what was spoken by the Lord
through the prophet will be fulfilled
there's that word right how did he
fulfill Isaiah by being born of the
Virgin
yes so where do you get fulfill meaning
follow every jot no no fulfill means he
came to realize and bring to pass all
that the law and the
prophets said and pointed
to right here's another one go to
Matthew 23-
15 look at that word
fulfilled I'm there now when they had
gone behold an angel of the Lord
appeared to Joseph in a dream and said
get up take the child and his mother and
flee to Egypt and stay there until I
tell you for Herod is going to search
for the child and kill him
keep writing you stopped I don't why you
stopped no no good all good all good so
Joseph got up and took the child and his
mother while it was still night and left
for Egypt he stayed there until the
death of Herod this happened so that
what had been spoken by the Lord through
the prophet would be fulfilled fulfilled
yeah so that means he obeyed the law of
Moses no has n it means he fulfilled
what the prophet said out of Egypt I've
called my son so where did you get
fulfill means I've called you to follow
the commands of
Moses right right right about Matthew
2:23
223 and and came and settled in a city
called Nazareth this happen so that what
was spoken through the prophets will be
fulfilled there's that word fulfilled
again right he shall be
called yeah so this tells me when
someone quotes me Matthew 51 1718 say so
see Jesus bound you to the law of Moses
that tells me their ignor is in Bible
butcher they haven't read it right once
then I know this guy doesn't know what
he's talking about oh here's another
Bible butcherer just like s butchering
scripture yeah I interpret the word
fulfill in light of Matthew and I
continue reading fulfill doesn't mean
Christ says hey I'm gonna slavishly
follow the law of Moses and you too in
point of fact did he not violate the law
of Moses
when he allowed lepers and women with
bleeding disorders touch him right and
Matthew oh I don't I actually didn't
even wow you're right and Matthew
814 a man withy said if you're willing I
can be made clean and Jesus full C was
willing and touch them
right yeah they weren't supposed to be
they were that's crazy that's so
true
quarantine those with infectious skin
disease you're supposed to be you're
supposed to clean yourself but he yo
that's true what about the woman with
the bleeding disorder for 12 years which
is found in Matthew 9 it's found in Mark
5 and it's also
found in Luke 8 read Luke 8 43-48 that's
crazy a woman with a bleeding disorder
must be quarantine because you can't
touch her or anything she touches
because it makes it richly impure she
touched Jesus's garment and she was
healed that's wow I I totally didn't
even put that together that's so true
tells me these people don't know the
Bible That's Why They disgust me when
they quote matthew8 all that they're
Bible perverts man now you see why I
have no compassion because someone who
doesn't know the Bible can be duped by
them oh think not I came to destroy law
problem fulfilled number one we don't
say he destroyed it but number two
fulfill doesn't mean what you think
meaning all point to him and he
consummates completes
perfects and brings out the true meaning
and it's his application that we
follow that's good so that's how I
answer them so don't let him butcher
that passage BR say can you read on a
little bit more right right right what
does he go on to say about fasting and
how to fast and how to pray that's not
in the law and the prophets that's all
him right yeah yeah because he's trying
to bring out the meaning of the law
prophets that awaited for him to then
consummate and complete them because
they find their completion in him which
is why we go to him in fact do you want
me to blow you away one more example I
mean I'm yeah I'm
I'm it we're told that the law of God
was brought near to the Israelites so
they didn't have to search it out right
right okay I want you to go to
Deuteronomy 30
you're going to read 10- 14 because I'm
gonna show you what the Torah is now you
ready guys get ready for this one
Deuteronomy 3010
to4 there Moses is talking about the law
that God brought here so they didn't
have to search it out they didn't have
to look for God's word and his will well
what is God's will it was brought near
to you right right Deuteronomy 30: 10-
14 Deuteronomy
30:10 if you obey the Lord your God to
keep his Commandments and his statutes
which are written in this book of the
law if you turn to the Lord your God
with all your heart and
soul for this commandment which I am
commanding you today is not too
difficult for you nor nor is it too nor
is it far
away it is not in heaven that you could
say who will go up to heaven for us
brother guys it's not in heaven so you
can say who will go up to bring it down
who's going to bring this the command of
God down from heaven you don't need to
go to heaven and nor is it in sh for you
to go down into depth to bring it up
right keep reading okay yeah I'm gonna
read it again because I want to make
sure I remember this this is very see
how what Paul does with it what Paul's
gonna do with this statement go
ahead okay I'mma read 12 again it is not
in heaven that you could say who will go
up to heaven for us and get it for us
and Proclaim it to us so that we may
follow it nor is nor is it beyond the
sea that you could that you could say
who will cross the sea for us and get it
for us and Proclaim it to us so that we
may follow it on the contrary the word
is very near you in your mouth and in
your heart that you may follow it oh so
what's near you the word right right he
say go to heaven and bring it down or
cross the Seas right right now let me
shock you what Paul does with this and
Joel you'll be after this Joel let me
shock you what Paul does with this guys
did you hear what Moses said about the
law you don't need to go up to heaven to
find God's word you don't need to cross
the Seas to find it it was brought near
to you in your mouth it's revealed so
now you know God's word he brought it to
you Paul takes this very passage look
what he does with it go to Romans 10 6-7
read Romans
106 all the way to 9
yeah watch guys look what he does but
the righteousness based on faith speaks
as follows do not say in your heart who
will go up into
heaven that is to bring Christ down wow
he took what was said about the law and
he applied it to
Jesus that's correct yeah what you
quoted was Deuteronomy 30 it says do not
go to heaven to get the law because it's
already brought down right but he said
no that's not about the law it's about
Jesus because
now for who will descend into the abyss
that is to bring Christ up from the
dead but what does it say the word is
near you in your mouth and in your heart
dude you just read that about the law of
Moses but Paul said no it's about Jesus
so what is that word now read what the
word is nine to 10 that got you that is
the word of faith which we are preaching
that if you confess with your mouth
Jesus as Lord and believe in your heart
that God raised him from the dead you
will be saved so why are you trying to
bind me to the law of
Moses Paul just told you Jesus is your
Torah he's your
law and you confess him with your mouth
and believe in your heart he is your law
and you keep him yeah so why the hell
are you trying to bind me to the law of
Moses right right I appreciate that
because I've been telling
game over this exactly no it's over dude
yeah because Deuteronomy 3010 of 14 what
you read was about the law of Moses Paul
says the law is not the reality it is a
shadow and Jesus is the Fulfillment he
is our Torah we keep him we keep him yes
amen he is the word on our tongue that
we confess Jesus is your Torah that's it
right here